hey guys my name is just McDonald and
it's the 11th off februari for your
daily dose on water mass is going on
with cleaner mom on you it's been smut
news and spoiler alert it's nothing good
remember his curiosity game the one with
the big cube that everybody was chopping
into and then he promised that the
player that took out the final cube
would get a life-changing prize well it
turns out he didn't brian henderson the
20 year old kid who was promised all of
this glory and a cut of goddesses
profits has barely been able to get
reply emails from 22cans let alone a
penny in cash he in essence won the game
in May of 2013 he was supposed to
receive a God of gods title in molly's
new game goddess that would enable him
to have powers in certain multiplayer
modes modes which as you might remember
from yesterday have not and potentially
will not materialize Henderson has said
that his email 22cans persistently every
month and received no word as to what
would be happening with his prize
Eurogamer contacted the studio for
comment and mourn you replied he should
have a contact here that's pretty shoddy
for us not to keep him posted I totally
and absolutely and categorically
apologized that isn't good enough and
they'll take it on my own shoulders that
I should have made sure he was
communicated with we will from today
onwards do that is slightly less cringey
news but only slightly the first trailer
for the upcoming hitman movie agent 47
has been revealed it looks exactly as
blockbuster action film as you'd expect
from Hollywood although that doesn't
really fit the hitman game losing
stealth bonuses doesn't seem to be
worrying this version of agent 47 and as
many of you quite rightly pointed out
it's not going to get a very good score
at the end of the level with all those
antics this is a reboot of the original
2007 hitman film starring Timothy
Olyphant and the film stars homeland
Rupert Friend and Zachary Quinto and the
drama over revolves DLC continues today
and it's probably not going to
that's a total rock considering that
it's now been discovered that all of the
valves day 1 launch DLC adds up to a
hundred and thirty-six dollars that's
one hundred and thirty-six dollars if
you buy every piece of DLC available
right now on top of forking out an extra
60 bucks for the game there are forty
four pieces of optional DLC available at
the moment ranging from cosmetic skins
costing you a few dollars to the $25
evolved hunting season pass which will
eventually unlock for new hunters and
some extra bits and pieces all maps and
modes for the game will be free in order
to be inclusive of those who aren't
interested in DLC parent company take
two has been super pleased with how DLC
can deliver revenue for a long time
after launch site in GTA online as a
positive example of what chief executive
Strauss Zelnick calls the gift that
keeps on giving let me know down in the
comments if you think DLC has gone too
far or if you're a fan of it the way
that it is you can head to gamespot for
more news on things like a spiritual
successor to banjo kazooie and our
january game of the month those
everything I wanted to tell you about
today's we sure let me know what you
cared about and has me same time
tomorrow for some more news